-Our next guest is
a Grammy-nominated singer
and singer/songwriter whose
new show, "Conjuring Kesha,"
premieres Friday, July 8th
on Discovery+.
Let's take a look.
-Energy, spirit, ghost, demon,
whatever is in here,
how's it going?
I'm gonna do
a ghost-box session.
Hopefully I can talk to a nice
spirit through this thing.
You can talk into here.
You can use this
to tell me your name.
-Please welcome to the show
Kesha, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show, Kesha.
-Thank you.
-I am so excited.
One of my favorite thing about
paranormal investigation shows
is the tiny flashlight.
And I'm so glad you have --
[ Laughter ]
-Mine's bedazzled.
-Yeah, I could tell.
-Did you notice?
-It's both a tiny flashlight
that I've grown accustomed to
from these paranormal shows.
And with a real Kesha twist
on it, which is it's bedazzled.
-It sparkled.
[ Laughter ]
-You had a podcast
about the paranormal.
-I did.
Well, this story goes way back.
And again, I told him this
earlier, I haven't been on
"Late Night" in like years.
-Uh-huh.
-So we might ramble.
-Okay.
-So if we do, we get her
and we bring her back.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Okay.
-Before I ask about your show,
because you know,
it is Pride Month and you --
-Oh [bleep] -- Yeah.
Can I --
[ Laughter ]
-What do you mean, "Can I?"
If you can't, what are you
going to do?
[ Laughter ]
-Whoops.
-It's totally fine.
You performed at the legendary
Stonewall Inn.
-Yes.
-For Pride. Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to ask you, you and your
dancers wore something,
and guess what the network said.
"We have to blur it out."
-I mean, that is making it
seem way worse.
-I agree. I saw this photo
earlier, and it was not --
It did not deserve to be
blurred, but everybody decided.
-That's just beautiful butts.
-Yeah, it was beautiful butts.
-For Pride.
-It was for Pride.
I'm assuming that your dancers
were enthusiastic about
showing off their beautiful
butts as well.
-Absolutely. Oh, we were in
dance rehearsal, and I was like,
"Listen, my butthole
is going to be out."
-Okay.
-"So, if you would like to
and feel comfortable,
I invite you to join me."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I will say, I always feel like,
when I'm seeing a show,
I either want to see
no buttholes or everybody's.
-All the buttholes.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Options!
-Yeah. I just don't --
'Cause if there's just one,
then the whole show,
I'm just following that around.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
That would be very narcissistic
of me to just be like,
"Only my butthole."
[ Laughter ]
-Now on to the paranormal, so --
-[ Laughs ]
Speaking of buttholes.
-Do ghosts have them?
-Listen, I --
[ Laughter ]
-No, like, when you become a
ghost, do you keep the butthole?
-I can confirm -- You know what?
Actually, I might have to go
back on that.
So I have, like, a whole thing.
-Okay.
-I have a thing.
Can I tell you the thing?
-Great.
-Okay.
So I always loved
the paranormal.
I've had weird experiences.
My whole life has been
very weird.
And then during COVID,
I was, like, having, like,
existential crisis
after existential crisis
and just lots of anxiety,
and one night I'm sitting in bed
and I was like,
"Uh-oh.
Here we go." And --
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"My -- My brain's breaking.
I feel it breaking. It's going.
This is me.
I knew it was going to happen,
but here it goes.
We're going crazy."
-Okay.
-And then, like, I heard
a voice, I saw a vision.
My cats brought me headphones.
It's a whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
And, like, I understood what
love was.
I saw the whole universe.
I pulled back.
It was a microcosm of itself.
I got the -- got the picture,
right?
-Yeah. Sure.
-So the next morning,
I called my therapist
and I was like,
"Girl, it happened."
[ Laughter ]
-Did your therapist say,
"Did the cats bring you
the headphones?"
[ Laughter ]
-And I was like, "Yep."
And she was like, "Guess what.
Congratulations."
And I was like, "What are you
talking about?"
She's like,
"This is a spiritual awakening."
And I was like, "Wait, what?"
[ Laughter ]
And she was like this, "Yay!"
And I was like,
"This is the point?
Like, this is what I've been
working towards?
What? This is terrifying."
And she was like,
"Yeah, welcome."
And I was like, "Okay."
And so I decided to really,
like, lean into it. I started
writing music about it.
And I called my brother.
That was my next phone call.
And I was like, "Okay, my brain
broke. We're leaning into it.
We're making a TV show
about this
and we're going to go
find some ghosts.
Let's look for some aliens
and [bleep] it.
Let's get Bigfoot."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean...
I'll tell you this.
If I was a network executive
and that was your pitch,
I'd be like,
"We want to do 50 seasons."
[ Laughter ]
-Honey, that's the goal.
-Now, you have guests.
-Yes.
-You travel to sort of places
that you think might be
inhabited by the spirits,
the paranormal.
Are your guests -- These are
sometimes people you know.
Are they enthusiastic about
taking this journey with you?
-Yeah, so each episode is
a journey
to its own special place.
-Okay.
-So I call up my friends
and the really good ones
are like, "Fine."
And so, like, the first episode
is Whitney Cummings
is coming with me.
-She's great.
-The best.
Such a good friend.
I took her to a haunted prison
in the middle of
the Tennessee mountains,
and there was a demon.
[ Laughter ]
There was a demonologist.
She's upstairs, like, having
this beautiful moment crying.
She believes that she's
connected and is having
a full conversation
with a trans ghost.
-Okay.
-Which may be true.
-Sure.
-Downstairs, the demonologist is
screaming,
"Get her out of there!
It's a demon! It's a trick!"
And I'm sitting there
being like,
"Um...I'm not going up there
in case it is a demon."
[ Laughter ]
"But, like, Whitney's crying
and having, like, a really
beautiful, like, experience."
-Yeah. By the way --
-And I'm the host.
-Yeah. And as of two minutes
ago, a friend.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-You literally were like,
"Whitney is the best.
Anyway, I took her to a prison.
She met a demon
and I was like, 'Bye!'"
[ Laughter ]
I'm very excited
that you have this show.
This makes me very happy.
-Listen, it's like --
If nothing,
it's very entertaining.
-Yeah. I mean, I also might want
your therapist's number
because I feel like this is
the one I want, where I'm like,
"I lost my mind,"
and she's like, "Monetize it!"
[ Laughter ]
This has been an absolute
delight having you here.
Congratulations on your show.
-Thank you.
-Please come back again.
-Oh, I'm coming back.
-I feel like you barely --
I mean, if you haven't done
"Late Night" in a long time,
I feel like, you know,
the break paid off.
-Did I do good?
-You were fantastic.
-Did I do okay, you guys?
-Give it up for Kesha,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wonderful!
"Conjuring Kesha" premieres
Friday, July 8th on Discovery+.
We'll be right back
with Patrick Radden Keefe.